เฮ
[Música]
Olá, muito boa noite a todos. Sejam
muito bem-vindos para mais uma live da
comunidade fechada. Um prazer tê-los
comigo.
Por favor, me de um retorno. Vocês estão
me ouvindo bem? Clevan,
Dra. Patrícia Dias, sejam muito
bem-vindos pra live.
Eu vou esperar vocês me darem alguma
sinalização pra gente começar a
responder as perguntas. Mas hoje temos
25 perguntas, então vou ter que ser mais
objetivo nas respostas.
Eliseu dizendo que tá ótimo o áudio.
Obrigado. Cleidan também. Alice Boger,
boa noite.
Boa noite, Eliseu. Que seja salvável.
Quer dizer salvável, Alice? Você tá
falando que o vídeo não tá salvando isso
ou no sentido de que as lives não tão
boas? Não entendi. Se puder esclarecer
pra gente poder melhorar.
Boa noite, top 10. Não sei o nome, né?
Só tô vendo top 10 aqui.
Bem, vamos começar pra gente não perder
tempo. Depois Alice Vgame me responde
aqui.
Eh, vamos apresentar aqui as perguntas.
No seu novo vídeo da cocomina tem
orientação de usar junto com a comida.
Porém, se eu não estou enganada em um
antigo vídeo, a cocomina é indicada
também para ajudar a baixar a ferritina
alto. Então, quem já tem problema em
manter os níveis de ferritina adequados,
seria interessante não tomar curcumina
com a comida,
tomar o corcoflexo longe da refeição
fará efeito. Bem, a boa pergunta essa,
né? Fará efeito, sim. Farei efeito sim.
E você tá correta. A cuccomina realmente
tem essa capacidade de quelar o ferro,
não é um grande quelante ferro, mas sim,
pode quelar. É interessante então para
quem tem ferretina elevada, mas pode ser
problemático para quem já tem
dificuldade de manter os níveis
adequados de ferro. Então, quando eu
recomendo consumir curcumina junto com
as refeições, especialmente com gordura
e pimenta preta, é para maximizar a
absorção dos cucuminoides, né? acho que
ficou claro para vocês, pra gente poder
aproveitar os efeitos antiinflamatórios,
antioxidantes. Porém,
essa estratégia pode interferir sim na
absorção do ferro dietético da refeição.
Se você tá com ferritina baixa, pode
fazer diferença. Seria contraproducente
no seu caso. Então, para quem tem
ferritina adequada ou alta, não tem
problema de consumir a cucumina junto
com as refeições. Para quem tem sim
dificuldade de manter os níveis
adequados, o ideal seria tomar o
curcuflex ou qualquer outro suplemento
de gcumina cerca de 2 a 3 horas distante
das principais refeições. Aí no caso do
cucuflex a tecnologia de fitossomo, não
teria tanto problema você tomar ele fora
das refeições, ok?
Então, tomando longe das efeições, a
absorção será menor, mas com a
tecnologia de fitossomo, ela ainda vai
ser significativa e você vai ter o
efeito sistêmico da curcumina,
principalmente se você optar por
fórmulas que têm melhor
biodisponibilidade, o caso do cocoflex.
Então a diferença é que você vai evitar
a interferência na absorção do ferro
alimentar nas efeições.
Uma alternativa interessante para quem
precisa tanto dos benefícios da cucumina
quanto manter bons níveis de ferro é
tomar cucumina em um horário específico
do dia, longe das refeições principais,
pode ser em manhã, em jejum, uma pequena
quantidade de gordura como óleo de coco
ou manteiga.
Então, dessa maneira, você consegue um
bom equilíbrio entre aproveitar os
efeitos da curcumina sem comprometer o
status de ferro do organismo e monitora
os seus exames, a ferritina, ferro
cérico, transferrina,
tudo isso daí, capacidade de fixação da
da do ferro, tudo isso aí. Ã, vamos pra
próxima pergunta.
falar sobre o dedímero, valores ideais
para adultos e crianças na visão
integrativa.
Bem, laboratória vai dizer que o
dedímero ideal, não ideal, né? O dedímo
normal seria até 500 ng por ml.
Mas tem muitos pesquisadores que
preconizam
que em pessoas acima de 50 anos você
faça um ajuste pela idade. Aí seria a
seguinte fórmula: Idade vezes 10 nanog
por m. Por exemplo, para alguém que tem
65 anos, o valor de corte seria 650.
Alguém com 75 anos seria 750. Entendeu?
Então, em crianças, infelizmente, os
valores podem variar, mas
conforme a faixa etária e o laboratório,
não tem um consenso para criança, né,
como tem para adulto. Então, na visão
integrativa, mais importante que o valor
absoluto é entender o contexto. O dedím
elevado pode ser inflamação, pode ser
infecção, pode ser câncer, pode ser
estado próombótico, pro coagulante.
Então, infelizmente o dedímor muito
específico, OK?
qualquer estresse oxidativo,
não só trombose,
infecção pode aumentar,
disbiose intestinal, se tiver acentuada,
pode aumentar esse marcador. Então, para
reduzir o dedímero de maneira
integrativa,
a gente tem que primeiro descobrir qual
é a causa raiz da inflamação, atuar nela
e também atuar quando indicado no estado
prócoagulante. Então tem que otimizar a
vitamina D. A vitamina D, além dos
efeitos nos ossos, no humor,
um efeito de câncer defamatório, ela tem
um papel na regulação da coagulação. Não
é um papel principal, mas ela tem uma
atuação nesse sentido. Usar ômega-3 em
doses adequadas, usar antioxidantes como
resveratro, cetina, magnésio, garantir
que o intestino não está saudável. A
disbiose, como eu falei, pode perpetuar
a inflamação sistêmica mental de edímero
e aquelas coisas sempre estão cansados
de saber. Controle de este. Attividade
física regular, sono de qualidade,
cortar os alimentos pró-inflamatórios,
açúcar, refinados, processados,
industrializados, óleos vegetais comuns.
E se tiver persistentemente elevado,
muitos casos a gente tem que utilizar
anticoagulante,
além de investigar causas, né, que estão
subjacentes inflamatórias, como
resistência urínica, disfunção
endotelial e por aí vai.
Então, respondido. Próximo. Doutor Alan.
Entrei recentemente no grupo. Seja muito
bem-vinda, Edusa. Tenho Rashimoto e
trato apenas Cupuran. Há mais de 30 anos
e sempre sentindo cansaço.
Ultimamente muita fraqueza. Fiz quatro
hemogramas semanais. As plaquetas foram
baixando. Hoje fiz uma série de outros
exames que aatologista pediu. Estou um
pouco preocupada, mas acho que pode ser
por causa da doença autoimune. Bem,
deixa eu explicar aqui. Ela é nova,
então ela provavmente não sabe, tá lá na
descrição do grupo, mas é importante
frisar aqui que tem gente nova aqui. Eu
não posso fazer uma consulta informal
por aqui, tá? O objetivo do grupo não é
esse, mas eu vou fazer uma resposta
genérica.
que de maneira alguma substitui uma
consulta, é só uma orientação. OK?
Bem, vamos lá.
Pessoas que t has rachimoto tem maior
chance de desenvolver outras doenças
autoimunes. Pode ser de 25 a 50% de
chance maior de você desenvolver, por
exemplo, artriteatoide,
púrpura trombocitopênica, que é uma
doença autoimune que afeta as plaquetas,
baixa as plaquetas, anemia perniciosa,
que é aquela anemia que você tem um
anticorpo que ataca as células que
produzem ácido clorídrico no estômago.
Então o fato de você tratar apenas com
purã, na verdade, você não tá tratando
nada da doença autoimune. Você tá
simplesmente repondo o hormônio
tiroidiano porque você tá com
hipotiroidismo, mas tratar mesmo a
doença não tá tratando, porque a origem
da doença autoimune não tá sendo
abordada. Então
você pode ter ainda vários anticorpos aí
em atividade e esses anticorpos estarem
contribuindo para inflamação sistêmica
num quadro de doença autoimune. Então o
hipotiroismo mal controlado e a
inflamação crônica da doença autoimune
pode levar a diversas deficiências
nutricionais e desregulações
imunológicas que vão afetar todo o seu
corpo. Então é fundamental que você
continue com a investigação hematológica
para descartar causas mais graves. no
caso de, por exemplo, verificar se você
não tá com essa púrpura, mas
paralelamente
seria muito importante você avaliar
também vitamina D, B12, ácido fólico,
ferro, zinco selênium, ferro, zinco
selên são muito importantes aí pro
metabolismo nos hormônios tiroidianos e
também as vitaminas do complexo B e a
vitamina D participam disso, além de
verificar se existem outras
autoimunidades ativas, né? né? Então tem
que fazer os exames aí de marcadores
reumatológicos.
O cansaço e a fraqueza que você descreve
também são sinais de que pode haver
deficiências nutricionais ou mesmo que a
dose por ano esteja sendo suficiente.
Então a abordagem funcional, abordagem
ortomolecular tem que tratar a causa
raiz dessa autoimmunidade. Então a gente
trata Hashimoto com selênio, com
metiformina, com
milinositol. Esses três são muito bons
para baixar os níveis de anticorpos. E
você tem que fazer os exames de antitpo
antitiroglobulina para saber se tá alto
mesmo os anticorpos, OK?
e não só repor o hormônio, porque aí
você não tá tratando do base, tá só
repondo o hormônio. Então isso pode
fazer uma diferença significativa na sua
qualidade de vida e prevenir outras
doenças crônicas no futuro.
E aí fica à vontade, marque com qualquer
médico aí que trabalha na linha
funcional. Inclusive, se quiser marcar
comigo, a gente pode colocar o telefone
de contato aí para você. Se você tá
assistindo ao vivo, deixa eu ver se você
tá ao vivo. Edileusa,
não parece que está ao vivo.
Vai ter que ver depois
a live gravada.
Pessoal, eu não vou mais conseguir
responder pergunta ao vivo do do chat,
não. Tá tem tendo muita pergunta aqui no
documento, não vai dar mais, tá? Então
peço vocês para não fazerem perguntas no
ao vivo porque não vai dar tempo. São 25
perguntas, tá? Eu tô aqui na segunda ou
terceira. Terceira pergunta.
H teste genético tem função na prevenção
de doenças em caso positivo. Para
Alzheimer,
Kell, não sei que K, deve ser qual, né?
Teste genético seria mais indicado.
Boa pergunta. Tem vários testes
genéticos aí para Alzheimer, né? Mas
vamos falar dos mais comuns. Eles têm
uma função importantíssima que
antigamente não existia, que é de
conscientizar a pessoa para que mude o
estilo de vida. Porque antigamente o
pessoal pensava que fazer teste genético
era uma coisa muito ruim, porque se
desse positivo a pessoa tinha que pular
da ponte porque não tinha o que fazer.
Não, não é bem assim. Hoje em dia, nós
temos muito o que fazer para prevenir ou
tratar precocemente o a deficiência
cognitiva.
Então, esses testes genéticos vão
permitir a partir da identificação de
predisposições genéticas que você pode
atuar, né, com várias maneiras aí de
melhorando estilo de vida, melhorando
alimentação, fazendo jejum, atividade
física, fazendo treinamento cerebral,
meditação e sono adequado para você
poder prevenir ou tratar a doença.
Então, quais são os testes que a gente
mais fala em relação ao Alzheimer? O
mais conhecido de longe, né, é o teste
que não é preditivo da doença, ou seja,
se der alterado, não quer dizer que a
pessoa automaticamente tem Alzheimer,
mas que aumenta o risco, é o apoe. Aí
você tem a variante apo e 2, apo e3, apo
e4. O apo E4, um alelo aumenta quatro
vezes o risco da doença. Dois alelos
aumentam em 16 vezes o risco da doença.
O apo3 ele aumenta o risco da forma
tóxica do Alzheimer.
Então esse é o principal exame. Tem
outros, tem o Apoc, tem o Gabi e tem
outros aí menos conhecidos. tem o gen da
psen e o psen 2, que é um mais raro aí
do Alzheimer genético.
Então, mas aí o apoê é o principal
deles.
Então é importante entender que este não
é um teste diagnóstico ou apoê, tá? É
sim um teste de aumento de risco ou
diminuição do risco. Ele vai avaliar a
predisposição genética. Com essa
informação em mãos, você pode adotar
estratégias preventivas como otimização
da saúde mitocondrial, suplementação
adequada e sensata
e também o controle da inflamação
sistêmica e modulação do estilo de vida
para proteger a sua saúde cerebral.
Certo?
Ã, para a próxima.
Boa noite, Dra. Lã HDL de 57, LDL de
123, TCL 47, LPA 157, Lá. Vou deixar
vocês lerem aí que eu não, né?
De novo, vou repetir aqui não é consulta
médica,
sabe?
Informal, tá? Eu vou fazer a resposta de
maneira
a orientar você procurar assistência
médica. Bem, esses valores aí que você
tá mostrando,
o LPA
tá bem alto, tá?
Mas o LDL, não sei se você colocou
errado, porque LP de 157 geralmente não
é um valor, talvez eu esteja confundida
pela unidade de medida, mas o LDL de 123
tá OK, os trigger estão OK, né? 47,
Luína tá ótima, tá três, né?
Pressão aparentemente normal,
aparentemente não tem placa na carótida
nem histórico familiar. Eh, o ponto de
atenção é a lipoproteína elevada 157
nanomoles por litro. Ele é um fator de
risco independente genético.
Ele não baixa com estatina, então não
adianta tomar estatina para isso.
Tem um protocolo que usa vitamina C,
glicina, NAC,
eh, exanotinatoginositol
para LPA. Se você quiser,
eu posso te ajudar nisso, mas você vai
ter que agendar consulta.
E eu recomendo fortemente que você faça
exames adicionais para avaliar a
qualidade do seu LDL.
Então, existe um exame
especial que é o lipidograma avançado,
que é o perfil de lipoproteína.
geralmente é usada uma tecnologia de
ressonância magnética que ele vai
verificar o tamanho das partículas de
LDL e a quantidade de partículas
pequenas e densas de LDL, que é o que
interessa. Ou ainda, se você não tiver
acesso a esse exame, LDL oxidado. E a
terceira opção é você fazer relação apo
A1. A não é lipo proteína que você
mostrou, é apolipoproteína B dividido
por apolipoproteína A1. E pode ser
necessário fazer um score de cálcio
coronariano, que é uma angotomografia
coronariana.
Também tem o exame de proteína reativa
transsensível, dosar vitamina D,
dosarosistênas, você já dosou, né? Deu
10,9, tá levemente aumentada.
Dá para baixar isso com vitamina do
complexo B, OK? Então, tô te dando as
dicas aí e se precisar é só agendar
comigo ou qualquer outro médico da
medicina funcional para fazer avaliação
aí personalizada.
Quais os melhores tratamentos
suplementos para melhorar o linfedema
nas pernas associado às doenças
autoimunes com esclerose sistêmica de
jogreen em pessoa magra na pós-menopausa
que já tem boa alimentação, usa meia
apropriada e faz masserapia.
Bem, alguns pilares básicos do
tratamento é já instituídos.
Do ponto de vista de experimentação,
pode ser necessária vitamina D, dos
terapêuticas, logicamente após avaliar
os seus exames, níveis séricos. Você
sabe que nas doenças autoimunes é
importante manter a vitamina D no limite
superior ou ainda você pode fazer o
tratamento do protocolo cuimbra com
megga dose de vitamina D, mas sempre com
acompanhamento médico, porque tem que
fazer uma dieta específica e tem outros
suplementos que tem que tomar junto para
contrabalançar a questão do cálcio.
Ômega-3 é muito importante. Eu tomaria 3
g por dia de ômega-3.
Você
pode usar enzimas proteíticas, enzimas
digestivas tomadas longe das refeições
que ajudam a quebrar os imunocomplexos
do sangue. Aí tem bromelina, tem
papaína, você pode usar serra pepeptase
junto, que isso tem um efeito
antiinflamatório, reduz fibrose, reduz
inflamação tecidual, linfedema,
pode usar
a corcomina, né, que nós estamos
comentando aqui,
e o selênio também, que tem potencial
antiinflamatório e imunomodulador.
Pode usar o cocoflex.
Quanto as terapias físicas, se ainda não
faz, é importante fazer exercícios leves
de baixo pacto, como caminhada,
exercícios aquáticos, hidroginástica.
Isso estimula a drenagem linfática de
forma natural e considere a
possibilidade de bomba de compressão
pneumática intermitente para uso
domiciliar. OK? Isso é um complemento à
terapia manual. Fazer massagem
linfática, você já deve estar fazendo,
né?
Melhorar a função hepática. melhorar
fint intestinal se for necessário. Vai
ter que fazer isso em consultório
médico, porque são vias importantes aí
de drenagem do organismo.
Pode ser necessário probióticos,
pode ser necessário hepatoprotetores,
como o caso da criar na extraída do
cardo mariano,
certo? Tudo. Tô falando aqui de dicas
novamente que você deve discutir aí com
o médico que vai acompanhar o seu caso.
Vamos pra próxima.
Doutora, tomo magnésio na forma de
himalato
e treonato.
500 mg de cada. Minha dúvida é se eu
tomo D3 10.000 por dia, preciso tomar
magnésio glicina também ou que já tomo
supr necessidade por causa da D.
Aí tem que ver se você tá falando do
dimalato 500 mg a molécula toda e o
treonato molécula toda não é o
equivalente a 1000 mg, por exemplo, de
magnésio elementar.
Então, provavelmente a quantidade de
magnésio elementar que você tá ingerindo
suficiente
paraa dose de vitamina D.
Vamos lá, vamos calcular aí o dimalato e
o treonato que você usa contém em torno
de 15 a 20%
do elementar no caso de malato e 8 a 10%
no caso do trionato de magnésio
elementar. Então você tá ingerindo por
volta, se tiver certa essa conta, não
sei se você tá falando na molécula toda,
mas provavelmente tá entre 115 a 150 mg
de magnésio elementar por dia. Então com
10.000 de vitamina D diária, o ideal
seria você aumentar a 300 a 400 mg de
magnésio elementar.
Magnésia é muito importante para ativar
as enzimas que metabolizam a vitamina D
na famiva e também para equilibrar o
cálcio que será melhor absorvido com a
D3 e A2.
Então você pode adicionar mais magnésio,
não necessariamente outra forma, mas
pode, por exemplo, colocar o glicinato,
né, o bisglicinato, pode colocar até
cloreto de magnésio que você não tiver
diarreia para você poder atingir a faixa
ideal.
De novo, 300 a 400 mg de magnésio
alimentar por dia. Isso vai otimizar os
benefícios da vitamina D, evitar
resistência ao tratamento, prevenir
câimbras, constipação e calcificação de
tecidos moles, que é totalmente
inadequado.
E tomar o K2 também. Você pode estar
tomando aí, você deve ter errado aí, mas
é 100 a 200 microg por dia, não é
miligrama, micrograma.
O que mudou em relação ao Kelp Yodine?
Esse vídeo vai sair
essa semana ou no máximo semana que vem,
tá? Então resumindo, tá? Você vai ver o
vídeo depois completo, mas resumindo
essa história que acontece o seguinte.
Eu fui fazer um levantamento da
literatura e lógico
o kelp que eu prescrevo é de fornecedora
de fáculação,
mas eu vi uns estudos falando que o kelp
que é comprado sem manipulação tem tido
tem tido muita variação tanto na
quantidade de quanto tem tido problemas
de contaminação de metais pesados. E eu
fui checar lá com o fornecedor da
farmácia, não tem assim uma contaminação
de metais pesados, tem uma quantidade
mínima de metais,
porém não ficou muito clara a
variabilidade do iodo.
O fabricante demorou para responder e
depois mandou uma resposta um pouco
vaga, assim, dizendo que tinha uma
variabilidade 0,08%.
Porém, disse de um lote específico lá.
Ele foi meio meio assim, não foi? Meio
evasivo na resposta. Então, baseado no
que eu estudei e resumo da ópera, eu
sugiro que vocês troquem o o iodo kelp
por uma combinação de iodo metálico ou
iodo molecular, que é a mesma coisa, com
o iodo iodeto, tá? Iodeto mais iodo,
mais na faixa de microgramas, tá? e não
na faixa do Lugol que vai passar aí
vários miligramas, mas aí no vídeo vocês
vão ver melhor o que eu tô dizendo.
Qual sua opinião sobre Lugol para
tratamento de nódulos na tirióide? Não
gosto, tá? Isso vai tá no vídeo também
que nós vamos apresentar aí ou essa
semana ou a semana que vem. E nesse
vídeo eu explico que eh nos dados da
Dra. Isabela Wentes, que é uma
farmacêutica especializada em tireoide,
ela teve 25% dos casos que ela
acompanhou, que tomou Lugol e
desenvolveu hipertiroidismo
por conta do desequilíbrio do iodo com o
selênio. Eu sei que o Dr. Lai Ribeiro
fala muito que o selênio resolve
problema, mas não é bem assim, tá?
Então
eu não tô não uso lugol e vou parar de
usar kelp e vou começar a prescrever
iodo mais iodeto na faixa de somando
dois de 500 microg paraa maioria dos
pacientes. Isso não quer dizer que não
tenha pacientes que se beneficiam com
gol. Tem sim. Então você pode usar assim
duas gotinhas, três gotinhas de lugol em
casos selecionados,
mas não dá para ficar recomendando lugol
para todo mundo, porque 25% que vai
tomar nessa dose de 1 2 3 gotas vai ter
problema, tá?
Ã, eu tenho alergia a soja, por isso
tomo até 100 microg. Antes parava o
coração, mas agora isso estabilizou.
Você disse 200 microg no vídeo ontem.
Pode ser de 100 a 200 microg. Você pode
tomar junto ou duas vezes ao dia. Não
tem necessidade nenhuma de tomar assim
escalonado, não, tá?
Então é importante você ver se a sua K2
MK7 é de fonte sintética ou se ela é
claramente identificada como livre de
alérgenos de soja, porque a maioria é
extraída do NATO. Você sabe que o Natô é
soja fermentada, então tem que tomar
esse cuidado aí. OK?
Quanto a dosagem, já expliquei, 200
microg totalmente seguro por dia.
Você pode dividir duas tomadas, mas eu
não vejo muita razão para dividir. E
tome junto com uma refeição, porque é
uma vitamina liposolúvel, então a
absorção dela vai ser melhor com
gordura. E o peso 50 g, 50 kg, não tem
nenhum problema, né? Nenhum nenhum, não
é nenhum limitador, certo?
Agora é estranho você falar sobre o
coração disparando, né? Porque isso
geralmente não tem nada a ver com o K2.
Deve ter sido outra coisa que você
associou, tá?
K2 é muito segura. Nunca vi nenhum caso
aí de intolerância K2.
E ela, na verdade, ela protege o sistema
cardiovascular, porque ela direciona o
cálcio para os ossos e tira das artérias
e tira dos tecidos moles. Então ela não
tem esse questão de dar arritmia.
Isso é importante você monitorar a tua
vitamina D no sangue.
E uma regra geral para você ajutar a
dose de K2
é 20 microg
para cada 2000 unidades de D. Então, por
exemplo, 10.000 unidades de D, você
vai tomar 100 microg.
Eh, se você for tomar 20.000, 1000, né?
Você pode aumentar para 200 mg de K2. Se
você for tomar 40.000 no protocolo
Coimbra, aí você pode aumentar para por
volta de 400 microg. K2 é muito seguro,
tá?
É possível saber, aliás, deixa eu ver a
interações de vocês ao vivo de novo.
Peço para não deixar pergunta, mas pode
dar bom dia, boa noite. Eh,
[Música]
Alice Vogel colocou aqui que seja
saudável. Ah, não é salvável, é
saudável.
Saudável o quê? A live. Não entendi.
Tô vendo aqui os comentários de vocês ao
vivo.
Sim, Fernando. Eh, eu vou essa semana os
vídeos vai vir sem esses esses chamados
aí, mas eu vou voltar a fazer sim.
Eu acho que quanto mais gente entrar
melhor para vocês. Vocês vocês vão ter
mais gente para discutir sem briga, né,
pessoal? Por favor,
vamos continuar aqui. É possível saber
mais ou menos em quanto tempo a D3
costuma cair. Sou bem magra. Isso
fluencia na queda por ser armazenada na
gordura corporal? Sim, influencia.
Quanto mais magro, mais rápido cai. Mas
a vantagem também, quanto mais magro,
mais rápido sobe, né? Ah, o tecido
gorduroso ele funciona uma como espécie
de armazenamento. Então, tanto o gordo
vai demorar para subir a vitamina D
porque vai parar no na gordura, mas
também vai demorar para cair. E o magro
vai ser rápido para subir e vai ser
rápido para cair, né?
Em julho a minha estava em 152. Ainda
não sei, ainda não voltei a tomar.
Bem, a minha vida da vitamina D em torno
de 2 a 3 meses, mas se você for magra,
não vai ser esse período, porque você
não tem tecido gorduroso para armazenar.
Então, em julho tava 152, é provável que
em outubro você ainda esteja com níveis
adequados.
Eh, vai depender também do seu
metabolismo.
Então, seria interessante você dosar
novamente agora em outubro, né? Nós
estamos indo pro final de outubro para
avaliar onde seus níveis estão no
momento. Então, se eles estiverem na
faixa entre 40 e 70, você pode tomar
tipo uns 2.000 por dia de vitamina D,
não precisa tomar dose alta. Entre 2.000
e 5.000.
Lembrando de associar com a K2, né?
Porque a K2 é importante pro metabolismo
cálcio
e a K2 tem vida curta de 24 horas. Então
quanto a D você pode tomar até semanal,
A2 tem que ser diário, tá?
Bem, vamos pro próxima.
Eu tenho ali já só
repetiu.
Eu acho que repetiu. Pera aí.
Não, não é a mesma pergunta. Não,
não, mas é, é anterior, né? Isso aqui
ela deve ter copiado e colado de novo
sem querer a pergunta.
Considerando a calcificação nas artérias
carótidas, que abordagem medicina
integrativa oferece para tratamento,
focando não apenas na redução dos
riscos, mas também na identificação e
correções das causas raiz e na possível
estabilização ou regressão das placas
calcificadas?
Bem,
calcição das carótidas é um processo
inflamatório crônico,
nós precisamos pensar nele como processo
inflamatório.
Então,
não é só questão de colesterol, como os
cardiologistas gostam de pensar.
É importante reduzir inflamação
sistêmica.
Isso vai ser importante através da
mudança da dieta, atividade física, do
jejum, do sono adequado, do controle de
estresse e também suplementação do
ômega-3
em doses terapêuticas.
Curcumina é uma boa também, né? O
cucuflex,
pelas propriedades antiinflamatórias,
capaz de reduzir a placa.
otimização da gluta
importante
aí no caso seria tomar naclicina, né?
São os precursores principais
para poder controlar o efeitos radicais
livres, né? que aí a glotationa vai ser
o antioxidante master aí para isso.
Importante também investigar a
deficiência de magnésio, vitamina D,
pensar em experimentar esses dois,
pensar se tiver deficiência de
experimentar selênio,
eliminar os alimentos inflamatórios,
como sempre, que eu especialmente glúten
e derivados do leite,
avaliar LDL, né, tentar verificar a
questão do LDL oxidado e das partículas
pequenas e densas de LDL ou a relação a
por B, poar
e fazer as avaliação completa desse
paciente, né? Com essa abordagem
fatorial focado nas causas raiz, nós
conseguimos estabilizar as placas e tem
um tratamento que eu passo também que
vai natoquinase, piquongenol,
vai os precursores do óxido nítrico, tem
o S7, tem o novaline, tem elcitrulina,
aí coloco um cataíbos também, tá? Então,
eh, tem essa receita aí de prevenção de
atrasose, que inclusive eu tomo. Se você
for ver meu vídeo lá dos meus
suplementos, eu tô falando disso lá
também.
Ã, respondida. Próxima. Gostaria de
saber mais sobre a dosagem do combo da
energia elcarnitina com enzima Q10 e
PQQ.
Minutinho só.
Deixa eu ver se tem pergunta chegando.
Ah, chegou mais três perguntas no
questionário aqui.
Depois a gente vai ver
bem. Queria saber sobre dosagem do combo
el carnitina com enzima Q10 PQ. Porque
aqui é geralmente uma dose de 20 mg por
dia.
10 a 20 mg é um tipo caro. L cararnitina
pode ser desde 100, 200, 300, 400, 500,
que não tem limite praticamente com
enzima, mas a maioria seria 200 mg por
dia. E elarnitina começa com 500 mg, mas
pode ir tranquilamente para 2 g, 3 g por
dia.
OK?
E lembrando que para entrar no cérebro,
barreira hematecefálica, a forma
preferível é acetilicarnitina.
Então, se você usar puder usar esses
três, é top
e é melhor tomar pela manhã junto com
alimentos, porque esses são
lipossolúveis
ou pode tomar antes do treino.
Obviamente que as doses vão variar
conforme o objetivo e o peso da pessoa e
o gasto energético, mas essas doses que
eu falei são as doses genéricas.
Lembrando, quem toma estatinas tem que
aumentar a dose da cozima Q10, porque
eles depletam a coenzima Q10, que é um
dos substrato da via do mevalonato.
Lembrando que coisema que 10 atua
diretamente na cascata fossforilativa,
na cadeia respiratória mitocondrial,
fazendo bypass lá dos elétrons,
aumentando então a energia mitocondrial.
PQ estimula a formação de novas
mitocôndrias, né, biogênese
mitocondrial. E a licarnetina é uma
espécie de óleo que dá aquela
lubrificada no transporte de ácidos
grassos para dentro das mitocôndrias.
Aumenta a entrada de ácido grxo na
mitocôndria para ser queimado como
energia. e ácido grasso são os derivados
das gorduras para quem não sabe.
Então a carnetina ajuda a queimar
gordura basicamente.
Doutor, quando após 2 horas ou mais
começamos a sentir aquela queimação no
estômago e aia, isso significa que o
estômago está com falta de ácido
clorídrico, correto? O que acontece com
os alimentos, suplementos que ingerimos,
o organismo não vão absorver, não
absorvendo quais as consequências que
uma pessoa irá sentir, qual é a solução.
Depende, tá? Não é todo mundo que tem
dor de estômago que tá com falta de
ácido clorírico, não tá?
Pode ser excesso, que não é o mais
comum, mas na maioria das vezes é falta,
que é hipocloridria.
Então o que que acontece? Com a falta do
áculírico no estômago, os alimentos não
são bem digeridos, ficam fermentando
estômago e a válvula também
esôfago
que eh a válvula que tem entre isôfago,
estômago,
o esfinnter esofágico, ele fica mais
relaxado e o conteúdo do estômago sobe
pelo esôfago, queimando o esôfago, tá?
Então tem esse problema da fermentação
no estômago e do refluxo que acontece
quando tem pouco ácido no estômago.
Então quando você tá com alimento
fermentando o estômago, isso causa
distensão por gases, causa pressão. Essa
pressão atrapalha mais ainda a questão
da válvula do esfíncter esofagiano e
empurra o conteúdo para cima no isôfago,
gerando o refluxo, né? Então a absorção
de nutrientes fica prejudicada,
especialmente ferro que depende de
ionização, né, para ser absorvido.
Outros minerais também acontece isso,
selênio, zinco, cálcio, também a B12,
que depende do fator intríseco do
estômago para ser absorvido, também tem
uma queda de absorção e também as
proteínas que dependem de acidez para a
sua digestão. Então tudo isso vai
prejudicado pela hipocloridria.
Você vai sentir mais cansaço, você vai
sentir problemas de pele, você vai ver
pedaços de comida não digerida nas
feeses, você vai ter gas, vai ter
distensão, vai ter desconforto e pode
desenvolver deficiências nutricionais
importantes ao longo do tempo. Então é
importante tratar a hipocloridria, mas
também identificar a causa que pode ser
gpilore, pode ser gastrite crônica, pode
ser gastrite atrófica,
pode ser uso prolongado de antiácido,
uso prolongado de prasol, né, que são os
inibidores de bomba. pode ser
deficiência de zinco. Então, zinco
carnosina muitas vezes vai bem aqui. O
tratamento adequado vai ser radical
gapilore se tiver gapilore. Lembrando
que o zincarnosina tem ação
antiagapilore. O própolis também tem
ação antiapilore.
Ã, suplementar ou ácido clorídrico em
gotas ou suplementar com cloro hidrato
de betaína com pepsina,
tá? Então, essas são as dicas que eu
dou. Importante fazer uma endoscopia
para ver se não tem uma úlcera dodenal
ativa. Em muitos casos é necessário você
tomar prazol aí por duas, três semanas
ou dois três meses até eh em caso de uma
gastrite ou esofangite ou doenite muito
acentuada, tá? Mas nunca utilizar prazol
por mais de 3 meses na minha opinião.
Próxima. Pod, por gentileza, vi um vídeo
sobre sua suplementação e gostaria de
usar cá de alho e orégano, mas tenho
dificuldade com manipulações. Como assim
dificuldade com manipulações? Quer
dizer, você não confia, o pessoal do
grupo aí vai te falar que eu recomendo a
integritar, tá bom?
Então, tem boas famáas por aí. Eu gosto
da integritar.
Deixa eu escrever para você aqui
e colocar na tela.
Eh,
essa famí tá
em relação se você quiser comprar
eh na internet,
você pode encontrar algumas máquinas
importadas. Tem o Black Garlic Plus,
orégano da Planta Paul.
que tem extrato de alho negro e orégano.
Você tem um Clean Nutra e Totara Health.
Tem formulações com óleo de orégano e
alho combinado. Você pode usar óleo
essencial de orégano da das empresas que
vendem óleos essenciais, como é o caso
da
caramba, me fugiu o nome. Me ajudem aí
vocês que trabalham com alencial.
Eh, Doterra é uma marca, tem aquela,
caramba, eu tô combinando branco, branco
o nome das famassas, massas, não, das
marcas de óleos essenciais.
O importante então é verificar se o
produto tem concentrações adequadas
princípios ativos, no caso o carvacrol
do orégano, que é o princípio ativo, e a
alicina do alho, né? Geralmente eu mando
manipular.
Então, se você quiser confiança, quiser
tranquilidade e não quiser ficar pagando
imposto lá do do site internacional,
você usa aí a farmácia integritar.
Bem, vamos pra próxima.
Obrigado, Alice, pela pelo comentário
gentil.
É o C vanan eu do terra falei. Se vocês
tiverem outras marcas aí, tem umas duas
boas marcas, mas sei lá porque me fugiu
aqui. Se vocês se lembrarem, me falem.
Doutor, em seu vídeo mais recente sobre
vitamina D indicado 400 mg de magnésio
alimentar diário. É 300 a 400. Essa
quantidade é uma média? É uma média sim
ou é o mínimo necessário? É a média do
mínimo.
As duas coisas. É a média do mínimo. No
exame de magnésio dos sangue, o ideal
teria ficar no quartil superior,
mais ou menos. Aí no caso, se você
quiser usar o conceito de quartil, seria
melhor você usar o magnésio
intraeleritrocitário como parâmetro, não
sérico, tá?
Então, 300 a 400 mg de magnésio
alimentar diário é a média do mínimo
recomendado para homens adultos, a
mulher que seria na faixa dos 300 mg,
mas eu tenho um paciente meu que toma
uma dose bem mais alta, 600, 800 mg, mas
não façam isso sozinho em casas, por
favor. Aí geralmente quando tomar doses
maiores aí é duas ou três tomadas.
A maioria das pessoas têm deficiência de
magnésio devido ao empobrecimento do
solo.
No Brasil, o solo é pobre em magnésio
naturalmente.
Lembrando que estresse crônico também
faz eh cair os níveis de magnésio.
E o magnésio é muito importantíssimo aí
para mais de 400 reações químicas no
organismo.
E se você tiver usando doses altas de
vitamina D no protocolo para doença
autoimune, a dose do magnésio tende a
aumentar mais.
Então, se for usar o quartil superior da
parte de referência laboratorial, use o
magnésio intraretrocitário ou
intracelular.
OK.
Ah, deixa eu tomar um negocinho aqui.
Pera aí. Me deem só um minutinho aqui.
Eu tô com a boca meio sequinha aqui.
Vou encher a caneca aqui com uma água de
coco.
[Música]
Só um minutinho que eu derramei um
pouquinho aqui. Já vou.
Doutor, em seu vídeo recente sobre
antibióticos e uso do sacaromis bulard,
existem cepas mais adequadas de
probióticos a serem usados após os
antibióticos.
Em um vídeo do canal é falado sobre test
booster. É, testboster é um produto da
manipulação que tem
um um pool aí, umas cepas interessantes.
É, eu eu gosto deste booster.
Por quanto tempo seria feito essa
reposição?
Bem, vamos falar das cepas mais
estudadas para reposição pós
antibiótico.
Além do próprio sacarombulário que eu
falei no vídeo, tem também o lactobací
dos raminosos
GG, tá? Tem que ser o lactobací dos
aminosos GG.
E também tem ação em prevenir a diarreia
associada aos antibióticos. Como eu
falei no vídeo, não pode tomar junto com
antibiótico, tem que dar um intervalo de
pelo menos 3 horas para tomar se for
lactobacilo,
se for o sacaromis, que é uma levedura,
pode tomar junto com antibiótico.
Existe também estudos com bacilus
clause, que é um desses SBO, que é
aqueles eh probióticos que vem do solo,
né, soy based.
Ele é interessante porque ele resiste
também à ação dos antibióticos, o
bacilos claus
o teste boost, como eu falei, eu gosto
um bom produto, especialmente para
intestina irritável
e o tempo de uso pelo menos 30 dias após
o término dos antibióticos.
Isso para dar tempo suficiente paraa
microbiota restabelecer.
Alguns passa podem precisar de 60 dias.
Isso vai depender de quantos ciclos de
antibióticos foram feitos e como é que
tá a salv intestinal de base,
tá? Então, lembrando, pode tomar o claus
e os sacaromices com antibiótico, mas
para tomar lactobacíos tem que ser duas
a tr horas do antibiótico para poder não
deixar matar o lactobacío.
Pronto, próxima.
Caramba,
isso aqui é um não é uma pergunta, isso
aqui é um relatório.
Eu vou deixar vocês lerem, tá pessoal?
Para poupar um pouco minha voz.
Rapaz, eu não sou especialista em em
criar galinha não. Eu não tenho
galinheiro lá em casa não.
Ai, caraca.
[ __ ] meu. Desculpa, pessoal.
É que realmente o pessoal, eu me sinto
assim
até
lisongeado que vocês acham que eu
entendo de tudo, né? Eu tento responder
da melhor forma possível, mas esse
negócio aqui tá meio além do meu
alcance. Vou tentar ajudar, viu?
Vamos lá.
Vamos lá. O que eu pude levantar da sua
pergunta é o seguinte. Vamos lá.
Toda a galinha poedeira produz ovos
naturalmente sem precisar do galo, ok?
Isso faz parte do ciclo reprodutivo da
galinha, não é nada de antinatural ou
partenogênese.
O galo vai servir para fertilizar os
ovos, caso você queira reproduzir, né,
fazer pintinhos, tá? Mas a produção de
ovos em si é natural, não é patenogênese
e não depende do macho
e não tem assim um hormônio específico
na ração. Eles colocam um hormônio na
ração, sim, mas não para partenogênese
ou para galinha pro ovo. Eles colocam
hormônio na ração para poder aumentar o
tempo, não aumentar o tempo, diminuir o
tempo que a galinha vai ficar adulta,
tá? para ela produzir o ovo mais rápido,
mas não é porque se não desse esse
hormônio ela não
poria ovos, tá? OK.
Então, ovos inférteis eh são mais
seguros para consumo, né? Porque não tem
o embrião se desenvolvendo
e é o que você consome no mercado. Essa
que eu pesquisei para te responder da
outra pergunta, né? Apesar de não ser
especialista nisso, essa galinha em
Brapa 051,
ela não é transgênica, é resultado de
cruzamento seletivo entre as raças Rod
Island Red e Plymov Rock.
Ela é rústica e é boa para criação
caipira, né?
Mas se for caso, você vê uma consultoria
aí com alguém que mexe com isso. Eu não
tenho garinheiro em casa, tá?
Sobre a sua dúvida de linhagem
selecionada,
o melhoramento genético por seleção não
é transgenia, tá? Transenia seria você
introduzir um gene
artificial ou estranho na galinha.
E essa questão de selecionam genética ou
melhoramento genético é uma coisa antiga
na humanidades. Eh, os humanos já fazem
isso, querendo ou não, há milhares de
anos, né? Foi assim que surgiu as aças
de cães, de gatos, de galinha. Então não
é transício aí, tá?
Então a rapa 051 e a Isa Brown são aves
melhoradas por cruzamentos tradicionais,
não é poreminação
ou engenharia genética, OK? Então isso é
feito para melhorar produtividade,
rusticidade, adaptação, mas elas são
naturais, não tem manipulação genética.
Então, para ser o projeto de manter um
plantel reprodutivo próprio, você vai
precisar sim comprar machos dessas
linhagens junto com as fêmeas na
proporção de um galo para cada 8 a 10
galinhas. Aí você vai ter ovos férteis
para poder chocar naturalmente, para
poder renovar o seu
eh rebanho, digamos assim, né? Ou até
mesmo usar a chocadeira, né? OK. Mas
assim, gente, eu não sou especialista em
galinheiro, tá? Por favor, tô tentando
só ajudar.
Estou usando DHA 10 mg cápsulas
micronizadas. Acha uma boa dose? Hum,
Joel, mulher. Sim, para mulher é uma boa
dose. Ou seria melhor tomar duas
cápsulas 20 mg? Não, 20 mg para você,
pra maioria das mulheres, não seria o
suficiente.
É lógico, vai depender dos seus exames.
OK?
Tô responder de maneira genérica,
OK? Vai depender da idade, vai depender
de sintoma. Geralmente 10 mg é uma boa
dose pra maioria das pessoas.
Agora tem caso de doença autoimune que
eu já usei dose de até de 100 mgem e
mulheres, mas eu tava tratando a doença
autoimune, não era para reposição.
Então é importante dosar o de sufatado
no sangue. Se você puder também dosar o
Deia salivar para ver onde você tá.
Mas geralmente mulher com 10 mg de
prasterona, que é o nome que tem na
manipulação do Deia, já é suficiente.
Para homem já geralmente é na faixa de
25 a 50,
certo?
Ã, pergunta de Ivan. Qual probiótico
você recomenda para uso contínuo?
nenhum, porque geralmente os probióticos
você tem que fazer
eh reveslamento,
mas aí você vai priorizando os
lactobacidos acidófilos, o bif
bactériolactes,
o lactobacíos aminosos, os sacaram
polares. Esses são os mais estudados,
tá?
Vocês
escolhem um produto entre 10 a 30
bilhões de unidades formadoras de
colônia de FCS
e vai revesando nas cepas. Aí você vai
usando de cinco a oito cepas diferentes.
Mas também não precis ficar tomando
probiótico resto da vida. Você pode usar
probiótico por alguns meses, parar de
usar e você segura com os prebios são as
fibras, tá?
Se puder de preferência a produtos que
tenham resistência ao pegar do estômago
para que as bactérias cheguem mais
preservadas do intestino.
Associe as fibras, são os prebióticos,
tá bom? e faça componente médico em
conjunto.
Qual o melhor horário para tomar o ácido
alfalipoico? Isso tem que ser longe das
efeições.
Ã, o alfalipoico, ele é um suplemento
que pode dar uma queimada no estômago,
né?
ele vai ter uma melhor absorção longe
das refeições, apesar dele ser
anfifílico, né, tanto lipossolúvel
quanto hidrossolúvel.
Eh, então os alimentos prejudicam o
álfalipoico na sua absorção,
especialmente os alimentos ricos em
ferro, magnésio ou cálcio.
Então, tente tomar 30 minutos antes das
principais
200 mg. Essa é a dose média, né, do
álfolipo.
Você pode aumentar até para 300 mg duas
vezes ao dia. Pode ser meia hora antes
do almoço, meia hora antes do jantar,
por exemplo.
E lembrando que doses acima de 600 mg de
alfalipo que pode afetar o funcionamento
tiroidiano. Então, fica atento quanto a
isso.
E se você tiver desconforto gástrico com
facilidade, manda fazer as cápsulas com
proteção gástrica, que é chamadas DR
caps, né?
são as gastrorresistentes.
Lembrando que ófalipoico é um agente
muito bom aí para regular a glicemia,
mas se você tiver tendência aí
hipoglicemia pode baixar e dar sintomas,
então tem que ir com cuidado.
A carne vermelha eh tem relação com
aumento de ferritina?
Sim, tem a ver.
com aumento da ferritina, tanto que a
gente pede para reduzir a carne vermelha
quando a ferritina tá alta,
porque o ferro da carne vermelha tem
alta biodisponibilidade, né? Então esse
ferro é muito absorvido porque ele tá no
grupo M lá
e que o organismo consegue absorver
muito bem.
O consumo regular de carne vermelha é
uma grande polêmica na literatura, mas
paraa maioria das pessoas o consumo
regular de carne vermelha não é um
problema regular que eu falo é todo dia,
né? Duas a três vezes por semana.
E a maioria das pessoas têm um mecanismo
de regulação, de excreção de ferro.
E quando a feritina está alta,
geralmente é porque tem inflamação ou
tem a hemocromatose. Aí você tem que
tratar a hemocromatose ou a inflamação e
enquanto a feitina tiver alta restringir
o consumo de carne vermelha para no
máximo duas vezes por semana.
Além da hemocromatose que eu falei,
inflamação sistêmica, pode acontecer
também doenças hepáticas, alcoolismo ou
algumas infecções como causa da ferina
alta.
Todo mundo que tem fertaluta tem que
passar por uma avaliação médica geral e
buscar a causa da raiz dessa inflamação
ou desse problema hepático ou desse
problema associado.
Lógico, se você quiser eliminar a carne
vermelha por outros motivos, pode
eliminar, mas geralmente eu falo pr os
pacientes não eliminar, só reduzir o
consumo de carne vermelha e aumentar o
consumo de arroz negro ou vermelho que
tira ferro do organismo.
Próxima pergunta.
Praticamente todos nós já tivemos
infectados pela COVID via vacina ou
porque apenas pegamos a COVID.
Existe algum protocolo eficaz para
evitar COVID longa?
Olha, para evitar eu nunca li nesse
sentido, porque na verdade a COVID longa
que acontece aí em até 30% dos pacientes
que pegaram o COVID, ela é tratada, né?
Agora, evitar a COVID longa é meio
complicado, porque seria o equivalente a
você evitar o contato com vírus, que é
complicado, né? Você pode fazer, mas aí
não faria tanto sentido, porque aí você
teria que tá ativamente fazendo a
prevenção por anos a fio.
Eu acho que quase ninguém tem saco de
ficar tomando suplemento sem ter
sintoma, sem ter nada, só que talvez vai
ter COVID longo, né?
Então eu não conheço esse protocolo
preventivo específico. O que você
poderia fazer é tomar os mesmos
suplementos que a gente usa para tratar,
só que em doses menores.
Aí você poderia, por exemplo, aumentar
consumir cucumina, quecetina, zinco,
vitamina C, ômega-3,
ã, talvez aí um bloqueador de spike, né?
Talvez uma dose baixa de vemetina,
talvez na toquinase com piquenol.
Então isso seria uma coisa um pouco
arbitrária, tá?
E lógico manter o o estilo de vida mais
saudável que você puder, né?
Isso seria muito importante.
E aí se a pessoa tivesse sintoma de
fadiga crônica, néva mental, alteração
de intestino e tiver uma suspeita que
isso tem a ver com o COVID, aí fazer o
tratamento eh realmente como COVID
longa, né? Seria esse o caso aí.
Ã, durante o processo de desparatização,
consumo de frutas como manga, banana e
mamão, as mais duas pode comprometer o
resultado do tratamento? A está falando
do da disparatização do protocolo
da Ruda Clark ou você tá falando do
protocolo
eh normal assim dos antiparasitários
drogas. Aí eu queria saber do que você
tá falando aqui, mas vamos lá.
É interessante moderar o consumo de
frutas muito doces, tá? o caso da manga,
da banana, porque o açúcar mesmo natural
pode criar um ambiente mais favorável
para alguns parasitas, tá? No entanto,
não é necessário eliminar totalmente as
frutas doces, a não ser que você tenha
um pré-diabetes aí, uma resistência
sururinca.
E aí, se você não tiver essa situação,
você pode consumir essas frutas com
moderação,
dando preferência para as frutas que tm
menor glicêmico, o caso limão, da fruta
vermelha, da goiaba, da maçã verde, da
perira. Então, o mais importante é você
realmente evitar açúcares refinados,
processados eh industrializados,
refinados.
Esses daí que são os problemáticos que
podem alimentar os parasitas de uma
maneira mais significativa. Uma mão, né?
Eu fiz vídeo sobre isso, aliás, eu fiz
um vídeo sobre outro assunto e muita
gente comentou e eu acabei respondendo.
A semente do mamão tem uma ação
antiparasitária.
O próprio mamão também tem caso da
papaína,
OK? Então, a paparina auxilia a digestão
e a semente do mamão tem comprovada a
ação antiparasitária.
E além disso, a semente de mamão ajuda a
reparar o tecido intestinal e modular o
sistema de defesa, o sistema imune.
Então, você pode consumir uma mão com a
semente durante o tratamento, você seca
a semente, mói e adiciona em sucos ou
saladas, tá?
Bem, vamos lá.
Tem perguntas aí que chegaram depois.
Deixa eu localizar aqui.
Um minutinho só.
Pronto, achei aqui.
Quero tomar Ivete para inflamação de
tendinete no ombro. Estou fazendo
fisioterapia. Isso procede
sim e não. Primeiro que a ibectina, ela
sim tem ação anti-inflamatória. Isso tá
comprovado
em estudos invitro e também estudos em
vivo em cobaia. Só que a gente não tem
aí nenhum estudo clínico falando do
efeito da esimectina para inflamações
assim ortopédicas, tá?
Então, faria sentido, porém não tem
respaldo ainda na literatura clínica, só
na literatura de base.
Então, entenda o seguinte, tá? Avectina
tem alguns efeitos colaterais,
geralmente são muito tranquilos, né?
Mais distortões visuais,
algumas pessoas podem ter cólica
abdominal, diarreia. Na minha
experiência, doses altas de mettinas são
muito seguras, não dá para ganhar no
fígado, como a imprensa falou.
Porém, tem muit outras coisas que t
evidência para tendinite, né? Pea,
palmitoria, tanulamina,
MSM, DMSO,
curcumina, né?
Curcoflex,
Bzo Serrata, garra do diabo,
sabe? Então, eh, se você quiser associar
o a, por sua conta e risco também a
imectina,
mas seria uma coisa aí menos evidência
sólida, tá?
Gostaria de saber se conhece algum
similar ao Boraprin da Vitafor, que a
vitamina E quantidade nele não seja
sintética? Sim, eu recomendo Natural Max
e são os tocotenais do urucum. Isso é
manipulação, tá? Natural Max hoje tá
sendo representado pela,
caramba, me fugiu o nome agora da
fornecedor da farmácia, mas eu fui até
visitar a fábrica deles lá no interior
de São Paulo
do
Natural Max. Natural Max, então é esse
estoco Trienois delta e gama do urucum,
tá? Esse que eu recomendo.
E evite o DL alfa tocoferol, que é a
forma sintética do tocoferol,
que na verdade é um problema, tá?
E esse Boraprin que você tá falando é
uma associação de três olhos, é
borragem, prímola e virin.
Eu recomendo você usar o Natural Max.
H marcar como respondida.
Médico de minha esposa passou uma
formulação para p de peso. Beberina 300,
piogglitazona 30, espiromactona 25 e
citrocinenses 200. Vi cada substância da
fórmula tem períodos do dia melhores
para consumo. Seria vantagem tomá-los
individualmente ou deve ser consumidos
juntos mesmo? Você já ouviu aquela
expressão
melhor feito do que perfeito? Às vezes,
se você dividir isso em várias capas,
você não vai tomar, né? Então esse que é
o ponto aí.
Então essa formulação ela combina
substâncias que atuam por mecanismos
diferentes. A beberina tem efeito
parecido com a metiformina. Melhor a
sensibilidade insulina atua na viâ
impecá bioquímica.
A piogglitazona é um antidiabético.
A espironactona é um diurético, tem ação
antiandrogênica. Então geralmente é
passado para quem tem espinha, acne.
Então, nesse caso, pode ser que sua
esposa tenha acne, não sei se foi essa a
lógica de passar espironactona.
Tem estudos mostrando uso combinado de
espirona lactona com piogglitazona. Eu
nem sabia disso. Para diabetes ou
pré-diabetes.
Bem, eu não recomendaria você separar
essas
esses elementos da fórmula para você não
se esquecer de tomar.
E a piogglitasona poderia ser tomada em
qualquer horário do dia. A espirolactona
também não tem restrição de horário. A
beberilha ela é tolerada melhor com
alimentos
porque ela pode dar desconforto a
gastrointestinal.
Então, tome a formulação completa de uma
vez, preferencialmente com a refeição
principal do dia
e faça com monitoramento periódico da
pressão arterial,
do açúcar do sangue, os eletrólitos,
especialmente potássio, porque a
espirolactona pode aumentar o potássio
no seu sangue. Bom, e a queda de pressão
arterial da espirolactona pode dar
tontura. Se tiver tontura e fraqueza,
procure o médico imediatamente.
Hum.
Muito obrigado pela gentileza, pela
confiança, tá? Até eu acho que eu vou
começar a criar galinha lá em casa lá.
Não, não tem espaço não. Só, só os
cachorros iam comer as galinhas também.
Não ia dar certo.
Ah,
eu pareci uma tonta na sala de tanto que
sorri das galinhas.
Ai, Maria Helena. Ai, Maria Helena.
Seja muito bem-vindo, Rafa. Seja muito
bem-vindo. É um prazer tê-lo conosco.
Boa noite, Rosiane. Depois você assistir
o vídeo gravado, tá? Lembrando para quem
é novo, os vídeos sempre ficam gravados,
tá? Ficam lá na área de membros do
YouTube.
Ah,
eh, eu dou trabalho com para com pessoal
aí, né, Cledivan?
É, realmente tem algumas fontes,
Fernando, que fala que não se usa mais o
hormônio nas galinhas já faz muito
tempo,
mas eu não acredito muito nessa fonte,
não.
Ah, deixa eu mudar aqui.
Hum. É aqui. Isso. Poderia comentar
sobre colesterol. Não, o colesterol não
é uma proteína, é um lípide, tá?
É uma, é um álcool. Quem é um álcool,
por mais que seja estranho vocês ouvirem
isso, quimicamente o colesterol é um
álcool, por isso terminei ol. Eh, mas
ele tem propriedades químicas que o
aproximam da gordura, por isso que ele é
um lípido.
Então, o problema aí, Cláudio, é que o
colesterol total ele é um ma ele é um
mau indicativo, porque o que interessa
no final do dia é a fração de LDL
que oxida e que glica. E essa fração é a
fração de partículas pequenas e densas
de LDL, tá? Então esse é um assunto bem
complicadinho, mas eu já falei em vários
vídeos no canal aí na parte aberta e a
gente pode ir comentando sobre isso aqui
também nas lives fechadas, tá? Então o
que interessa é a relação entre o
triglicérides e o HDL. Então o HDL tem
que tá 40 ou mais, especialmente
mulheres, e o triglicerides tem que tá
100 ou menos. Então o HDL tem que tá
perto do triglicerides, tá? Então, se o
tá lá 200 e o HDL tá 30, tá ruim. Então,
tem que aproximar os dois, aumentar o
HDL e baixar o trissé, tá? E medir a por
AO B. Então, se o apo B dividido pelo
apo A der acima de 07, o número é ruim
também, tá? Então, essas detalhezinhos
aqui, OK?
Eu
tô respondendo isso aqui, gente, porque
são perguntas assim, eu falei que não ia
responder ao vivo, mas como é um assunto
que interessa todo mundo, então resolvi
fazer uma exceção aqui, tá?
Obrigada, Alice Vog pelo comentário.
Ah, aí no caso a alergia da soja pode
causar uma liberação de estamina. essa
estamina dá a ataque cardíaco. Aí, aí
nesse caso faria sentido sim, né?
Não, suco de beterraba não dá esteatose
hepática, Eliseu. Não há nenhum problema
de tomar.
Bem, pessoal, já tá bom, né? Estamos com
1 hora 12 de live. Muito obrigado aí
pelo comentário.
Muito obrigado pelo comentário.
Ah, dentista pode prescrever CBD? Acho
que sim, Eliseu. Tenho quase certeza que
sim, viu?
Bem, pessoal, muito obrigado pela
presença de vocês. Avisem lá no grupo
pros novos que os vídeos ficam gravados,
que eles podem assistir depois. Quem não
pôde acompanhar ao vivo, deixe na
academia. Beijo no coração. Até a semana
que vem. Assistam os vídeos, vocês
recebem os vídeos com antecedência, né?
Vocês sabem disso. Da parte aberta vocês
têm a a prerrogativa de assistir antes
de todo mundo. Até a próxima. Ciao.
Ciao.